esta vez tenemos la siguiente ecuación
seis más tres veces w esto va a ser
igual a la raíz cuadrada a la raíz
cuadrada de dos veces w más 12 y a esto
le vamos a sumar dos veces w
dos veces w y como siempre te encargo
que pausa el vídeo y vea si puedes
resolver para w ojo puede ser que tenga
más de una solución entonces ten eso en
mente ok ahora vamos a resolverlo juntos
y lo primero que me gusta hacer siempre
que veo una de estas ecuaciones
radicales es aislar el radical de un
lado de la ecuación para después
elevarlo al cuadrado entonces qué te
parece si restamos dos veces w
dos veces w de ambos lados de la
ecuación aquí también voy a restar dos
veces w para que si estos dos se vayan y
me quede en radical sólo en el lado d
de la ecuación y que me va a quedar
bueno de esto de esto que voy a obtener
en mi lado izquierdo voy a tener
más y tengo tres de algo menos dos de
algo bueno me queda solamente uno desea
algo tres dobles dos w
es solamente w y esto tiene que ser
igual a estos dos se van y solamente me
queda la raíz de dos veces w más 12 de
lujo y ahora lo que voy a hacer ya que
solamente tengo el radical del lado
derecho es elevar ambos lados de esta
ecuación al cuadrado y como hemos visto
anteriormente hay que tener mucho
cuidado con esto voy a elevar este lado
izquierdo al cuadrado y también este
lado derecho al cuadrado y hay que tener
mucho cuidado porque este proceso de
aquí es un poco engañoso ya que cuando
él le vas al cuadrado un radical en una
ecuación radical como está y luego lo
resuelves puede ser que te encuentres
con una solución extraña a qué me
refiero con esto bueno vamos a obtener
el mismo resultado si elevamos la raíz
cuadrada positiva de dos veces w más 12
que si elevamos al cuadrado la raíz
negativa de dos veces w12 ya que cuando
elevas un negativo al cuadrado se
convierte en positivo pero estos tanto
el positivo como el negativo son
fundamentalmente ecuaciones distintas y
nosotros sólo queremos la ecuación que
satisfaga la ecuación que no tiene el
negativo y es por eso que cuando
obtengamos nuestra solución vamos a
probarlas en la ecuación original para
ver si llegamos a una respuesta válida
para esta ecuación inicial y elevando al
cuadrado que me va a quedar del lado
izquierdo me va a quedar bueno empecemos
por w
me va a quedar w cuadrada y después
tengo dos veces el primero por el
segundo 2 por 6 es 12 x w
es 12 veces w muy bien y después el
cuadrado de 6 y el cuadrado de 6 636 muy
bien eso del lado izquierdo y del lado
derecho que me va a quedar si observas
solamente me va a quedar dos veces w
12 el cuadrado y la raíz se eliminan y
ahora en esta cuadrática que tengo aquí
que te parece si la ponemos en su forma
estándar y para poner la forma estándar
lo que quiero hacer es igualar la 0 para
igualar la 0 qué te parece si restamos
dos veces w para eliminar este 2 w de
ambos lados de la ecuación tanto del
lado izquierdo como del lado derecho y
también voy a restar 12 también voy a
restar 12 de ambos lados de la ecuación
para que del lado derecho me quede cero
vamos a hacerlo si me tomo esta
operación de aquí que me va a quedar
bueno del lado izquierdo me va a quedar
w cuadrada y después tengo doce veces w
menos 2 w
es lo mismo que 10 veces w y después
solamente hay que hacer 36 menos 12 lo
cual es 24 muy bien y del lado derecho
que me va a quedar estos 2 evans estos
dos se van y simplemente me quedo con 0
muy bien y ahora veamos
cómo puedo resolver esta ecuación de
segundo grado en su forma cuadrática
estándar bueno podría usar la fórmula
general pero también puedo ver si es
factor isable a ver veamos dos números
que sumados te den 10 y que su producto
te dé 24 8 por 324 pero sumados con
teherán 10 6 y 4 perfecto es 64 entonces
esta ecuación cuadrática que tengo aquí
la puedo factorizar como w6 que a su vez
multiplica a w 4 a w 4 y esto es igual a
ahora si tengo el producto de dos cosas
igualado a cero para resolverlo
cualquiera de las dos o las dos pueden
ser igual a cero porque recuerda cero
por cualquier cosa es igual a cero
entonces de aquí voy a obtener que o w 6
es igual a cero o en su dado caso w
4 w
4 esto es igual a 0 en el primer caso si
restamos 6 de ambos lados voy a obtener
que w va a tomar el valor de menos 6 muy
bien y en el lado derecho lo que voy a
obtener es que w
es igual a menos 4 si restamos 4 de
ambos lados muy bien ahora lo que
tenemos que hacer es verificar si estas
dos soluciones son soluciones de nuestra
ecuación original recuerda nuestra
ecuación original es esta que tenemos
aquí seis más tres veces w esto es igual
a la raíz cuadrada de dos veces w + 12
ya esto hay que sumarle dos veces w
muy bien veamos si w igual a menos 6 es
una de nuestras raíces y para eso voy a
tomar este color y vamos a verificar w
igual a menos 6 y lo que voy a hacer es
sustituir lo justo aquí
6 + 3 que multiplica a menos 6 esto
tiene que ser igual a la raíz cuadrada
de 2 que multiplica a menos 6 a esto le
vamos a sumar 12 y después a esto hay
que sumarle 2 x menos seis muy bien
veamos que me queda de esto lo primero
que veo es que 3 x menos 6 esto es lo
mismo que menos 18 2 x menos 6 es lo
mismo que menos 12 y 2 x menos 6 esto
también es menos 12
entonces me quedaría 6 menos 18 lo cual
es menos 12 esto tiene que ser igual a y
aquí tengo menos 12 12 lo cual es 0 y la
raíz cuadrada de 0 bueno pues eso cero
entonces todo esto se eliminan y
simplemente me voy a quedar con menos 12
lo cual es completamente cierto menos 12
es igual a menos 12 y eso quiere decir
que w igual a menos 6 es una solución de
nuestra ecuación original muy bien qué
te parece si ahora probamos con mi otra
solución
wv igual a menos 4 y me va a quedar 6
más 3 que multiplica a menos 4 esto
tiene que ser igual a la raíz cuadrada
de 2 x menos 4 muy bien ya esto hay que
sumarle 12 y bueno a todo esto hay que
sumarle dos veces w es decir 2 x menos 4
ahora 3 x menos 4 esto es menos 12 2 x
menos 4 esto es menos 8 y 2 x menos 4
también es menos 8 y entonces me va a
quedar 6 menos 12 lo cual es menos 6
esto tiene que ser igual a menos 8 más
12 es 4 positivo
entonces me queda la raíz cuadrada de 4
y después tengo más menos 8
más o menos 8 ahora la raíz cuadrada de
4 es 2
entonces me quedarían menos 6 igual a 2
más
menos 8 lo cual es completamente cierto
entonces w igual a menos 4 también es
una solución de mi ecuación original y
ya acabamos perfecto esta vez tenemos
dos soluciones a nuestra ecuación
radical original